so uh legitimate question okay dick
girls yeah
Indulgence a lot there's a lot of it yes
and you have a serious tsf that has Dick
girls in it right yes I've always been
curious
how do dojinatas get into that like are
you not into it
I'm like half off right into it I'm not
like crazy about it what's the name of
the tank again did go was it ridiculous
yeah
right because it's like it's when you
think of like you know stereotypical
like dojin tax right like futa is
usually the first one people think of
right because I feel it's very much like
a I think there was a there was a pool
that faku did right of like the most
popular um search tags I'll post State
first date yeah that was like all over
the years I think it's like yeah I think
I remember seeing that it was like out
of like out of like the 50 states I
think it was like 41 States the most of
you tag was Futo yeah so it's like it's
just I don't know it's just this really
interesting thing that like
I think it's just so synonymous with the
dojin world especially yeah and a lot of
people are so like again it's like
another one of those things like lonely
and shutter where it's like a very clear
divide right but and yet it's like
weirdly embraced yes for some reason
right so it's like but like you'll know
like personally into it right no
personally I'm not like it doesn't
really do anything for me yeah yeah but
I understand like intellectually
how it works like right why it's
appearance intellectually
I appreciate it I appreciate it so I try
to put into the work because like you
know I want to explore that aspect of so
what so what made you want to explore
that side of things well you know like
I've never known it before I'm like
let's give it a try and like you know
the more I try work it then the more I
understand why it works yeah yeah you
know so it's like your mission I guess
is to like go through every single tag
to be like I'm gonna try and explore
every single one of these yeah that's a
good goal I think
putting your own twists on like every
tag yeah that's a really good goal is
that like a tag you've seen where you're
just like whoa
what what is that oh oh I'll tell you
when I find it eye penetration I've done
it
[Laughter]
appeal of that
so uh breaking laws of physics
physics
I penetration this year penetration
there's like belly button penetration
and it's all it all links to like sorry
yeah that made my like stomach
it's basically all what we call Leona
which is like a torture basically right
what a Twitter porn right oh wow yeah
that's that's like a really common tag
yeah yeah there's a lot of any of this
it's completely all new to me yeah I
don't read you innocent child
don't read anything
it is a vast World album what are you
thinking like how would you even
how did you do this physically the
orbital socket is like this deep so you
can find like maybe a way to do it I
mean I mean I think the point is you
can't do it physically that's the appeal
of it that's the appeal yeah yeah it's
like I I don't want to see it in real
life I don't want to try it in real life
this is incredible maybe you could
I mean that's one way to do it
you've you've just discovered a
situation in order to like achieve that
I don't know how much Incredibles Pawn
you think there is out there there's a
lot yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
made of rubber to make that work
realistically
yeah it's not like that's like one thing
I've always wanted to ask like a dojian
artist it's like when you find those
kinds of like you know non-vanilla tags
and stuff like that what is it about
like those non-vanilla tags that makes
you want to like draw about it or like
you know write about it or you know like
kind of well they try to get into it if
someone who is really talented before
and it's like you don't fall in love
with the the act or the tag itself but
you fall in love with the artwork right
right right right right
So like
um I don't know if you know who gujila
Sensei is I know the name he does like a
manga
um that's about reptiles okay oh yeah I
think I think I've seen like pizza
because femboys went honestly in this
free time right right and like I've
never been into Fanboys right but like
just Wheeling his stuff it's like oh
what's so good like this Fanboy is hot
yeah that's that's my exact experience
with asunagi because like a lot of like
his topics in his dungeons I'm not crazy
about to be honest like a lot of it's
just like whoa okay but the art is just
so good right yeah yeah they're like I
can't stop reading it it's like it's I
just look at it as like damn he can
[ __ ] draw people and situations like
action scenes like really [ __ ] well
yeah yeah and like I think I just
appreciate him on that aspect and I
think it's like I appreciate a lot of
Dojo knows just for that aspect just the
fact that like a lot of them are just
like really [ __ ] talented and honest
right right and it's like if I could
draw like that I would absolutely
[ __ ] draw that [ __ ] you know I was
like why wouldn't you it's just cool I
don't know I I say this because I can't
draw for sure porn is that what you're
saying
I mean look I'm just trying if I could
if I had the talent to draw porn okay
why would you not
I mean especially what they were doing
you know and the the churches that's
what they had right
people to draw like a really hot sex
scene I would absolutely draw my own
sexy yeah because that's just like a
power it's like I don't even have to
look for porn anymore I just [ __ ]
make it I'll make it I won't make the
pawn myself Thanos I'll do it myself
yeah exactly I mean like that's that's
why you do it that's what I do it yeah
because it's like you know you you look
around and you're like nothing there
that like just clicks for me yeah so
I'll just do exactly what I want to see
and you know what I think is cool right
so it's like yeah if I had the ability
to do that I [ __ ] do that in the
heartbeat absolutely so like what are
some of your favorite tags out of
curiosity um I think some of my most
well-known favorite tags are like
fragment one right sometimes birth
sometimes like um birthing birthing like
building a baby making a baby in in the
show
like well I mean metamorphosis had one
right well this is kind of not merely
not really I'm also I don't know much
but if you eat um
[Music]
this one chapter is all just birthing
because I wanted to just giving birth
just giving birth okay
okay
I was just looking at Connor when he
said okay and just the eyes dying you
laying around like okay
I wouldn't ask questions but I'm scared
to know the answers you won't have an
opportunity so just ask a task so yeah
the pregnant thing I can understand I
can understand that could be attractive
right yeah but what about the both
aspect is attractive well why not go a
step further when you go if you're into
the pregnancy already then why not go a
step further this is water that's the
attractive part well you you know just
well okay okay I'm just making sure I
understand that
you can be like I mean you could like
theoretically do anal while you're doing
it but like you know it doesn't have to
I guess you could yes
that is indeed a fact
the laws of physics
I feel a pattern which is just like well
you theoretically could do this
so I think what I'm learning is that
it's it's asking the questions that men
never asked let's [ __ ] it let's do it
yeah yeah let's give it a go I admire
the exploration yeah Okay carry on what
other things
um ishikan which is a cross species
yeah you know usually mixed in with
pregnancy and birthing right right okay
how many sauces can you put on the hot
dog like it's like a chef right just
like the ingredients okay okay and uh
well you know the normal stuff like you
know gang bang whatever you know so yeah
it's like vanilla can you just not do
vanilla anymore why not
go back to the classics eh like the
bloody one was Vanilla what was it
wasn't it I would have there's two
people and they're just not doing a
thing I mean I mean there's vanilla like
not exactly no no no there isn't no it's
not vanilla because there was a birth
scene what
it was how is birth not vanilla though
this man's like living on a different
like level of reality he's like I think
I think your version of vanilla and mine
is
gone like I'm like missionary go to bed
at 9pm watch a TV show you know that's
vanilla
natural right that's the standard Human
Experience okay that makes sense no but
I get that just the fact that you're
like what's the vanilla about birth it's
just like it's like third eye open it's
like oh my God you're right
this man's like another plane of reality
brain expansion means just like a
couples getting together vanilla no it's
like an attractive thing to teach to
baby born
I mean like the because there's um the
mother has to go through all these
stages right yeah oh and that's the
attractive part okay okay I think I
understand
I think I feel like you need to like
read some of it to like figure it out
yeah what are the tags I'm interested
um
that won't make sense to me that seems
hot yeah well I mean yeah issues look at
reviewers was [ __ ] massive right
because they're hot why not yeah exactly
exactly I mean technically like you know
the probably one was awesome yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly but no normally
normally we're talking about like
non-human right right yeah yeah yeah
um what else well you know the normal
stuff like you know uh transgender yeah
right one that I've been doing a lot
um what else have back doing doing well
you know I do Leona too the torture
stuff right right someone once in a
while
um
I recently did a
collaboration with a snug Sensei and he
did his uh compilation of like various
artists doing like girls who've been
who've had their own limbs cut off right
okay yeah I feel sorry for the FBI
agents of your search history
I've already seen some stuff like he's
like reaching for his third notebook all
right yeah write that one down sir
I have to go through all this [ __ ] later
yeah yeah
um I haven't done too much scat
right except like vomiting vomiting I do
a lot why
I mean like I'm secure genuinely curious
genuinely I don't know it's like it's
I'm not trying to be like derogatory one
of the moments where you where you feel
like
at your lowest when you're when you're
thought okay so there's kind of an
attraction to seeing people at a very
low Point yeah
yeah yeah okay okay I mean yeah so I
guess on the same level in terms of
vulnerability it's simple it's like
Metamorphosis right very vulnerable just
in different ways yeah yeah yeah exactly
it's the same emotion I guess just in a
different kind of scenario I just love
them just if you just took that
conversation out of context it's like I
do vomiting quite a bit and you're just
going why
well it must be so weird out of context
you know
I'm trying to understand this this one
episode has been like a gold mine I'm
just getting out of context Clips yeah
you know because I I like to think that
the podcast is is something where even
if we disagree like I said it's
something where we can come to
understand and kind of talk and share
even if I completely be like that is
[ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah yeah I still
think that you should be able to tell me
about it yeah yeah talk to me and be
like this is what it is and I'll be like
oh God
go ahead King I just want you to I just
want you to keep going purely just to
see Connor's reactions this entire
podcast just been golden it's just like
every so often you'll say something kind
of just like what and every time you say
something that I know is [ __ ] I
immediately look at Connor like there's
a lot of people who you know would kill
to be in this chair and talk to you
about this so I don't want to you know I
don't want to squad on
you know I'm I'm sitting on this side of
the table and I'm like sometimes I feel
like I should be over there
I love hentai right hentai is great you
know me and Samuel Jackson have a lot in
common yeah
both cultures I believe in that Clippers
I'm going to agree with that oh yeah you
don't like what's I know Jackson likes
that time you know and I almost feels
like hentai is so goddamn vanilla from
what's going on in the dojinshi world it
is it is
I'm watching it I watched a lot of the
hentai and I feel like what is happening
over there like I feel like I'm like
we're like the villa and you guys are
like fighting down on the streets what's
going on down there one thing I can
definitely say after after talking to
you is that I think I have vanilla taste
I used to say like vanilla that's lame
as [ __ ] but now I think I'm vanilla
your colleagues presumably don't all
draw or cover the same stuff as you are
they ever like bro chill like
it's always what I don't know okay okay
I mean it's always fun to see what other
people are doing right right yeah oh
you're doing that cool I can imagine be
like yes King yeah
episode we've got to ask you to
recommend us some Notions yeah and uh
we'll read it and talk about it actually
yeah
I'm gonna hate my life if you're going
through my category then I suggest doing
uh Hindu elves coaching anthropology
okay because I had the most fun writing
that one okay okay and so that's you
just explaining all the genres I guess
or it's like me playing around with a
lot of genres okay okay it's like short
stories like I know it's one continuous
like it's episodic
set characters doing like different
things every chapter okay okay see a lot
of these stuff really confusing for me
because I'm like am I supposed to jack
off I don't know when
you're not supposed to yeah am I
supposed to be here
I think it's just a matter of like if
you think the time is right yeah you
know how you write it you're like if you
if you want to just read this and
experience it do it or are you writing
it for like all right yeah you can go do
it I mean like some things I've been
thinking about for a while and like you
know that if you know I kind of let it
like work late yeah and then like I put
it on paper but other things it's you
know on a whim yeah right okay I think
yeah because you know like I don't jack
off to every Dojo you know sometimes I
just like like reading it because I like
reading it yeah I just watch porn yeah
no but that's the weird thing that's an
obligation yeah yeah yeah but that's the
weird thing right I'm not like that with
like porno hentai so like what is it I
don't know is there's something about
doujins where it's like it can literally
just be like a pick up and read thing
sometimes yeah I see people on the train
just right swiping through dojens yeah
yeah I'm just like this is a strong
world man but I just find that really
fascinating that like dozens can do that
yeah where it's like even though you
look at the contents of it and you're
like yeah I can definitely see someone
like jacking off to that that the fact
that you can just sometimes be like yeah
you know what I want to read it but I
don't really want to jack off to it I
just kind of want to read it I want to
read the Planet of the Apes yeah no
that's not to joke just curious right
yeah yeah exactly I think it's you know
why it's just gonna be so simple I think
it's because doujins aren't a hands-free
experience
right right
because you are you are holding
something yeah whether it's like you're
like juggling a lot of things yeah
exactly like like hentai you know you
can put that on the TV at least now you
can put it on a screen you know back in
the day you had to like find a way to
put that hold the book yeah
like even if you put on the screen
you've got to like Turn the Page yeah
you know it's it's not a complete
hands-free experience
I've always been curious like can you
view like porn in the same way or do you
just view it now as completely you know
just research or something that you can
incorporate into your own oh no I could
still you know totally okay okay
yeah it's all good that's when you know
it's good right
you're like finally some good [ __ ]
food
is it more of you more prefer to read or
watch
I'd rather eat oh that's interesting for
me that's like the complete yeah like
I'm a manga person rather than an anime
person right right right right so you so
it's more about like visualizing it and
kind of like it always works better in
my mind when I'm reading it I guess it's
like I'll do it instead of watching a
movie because you can like fill in the
blanks in your own way right yeah so
it's like you can make it a lot more
like sexy or like more for your taste
then perhaps the author intended right
right with words with like henta it's
like you get the full package and you
can't really change that you know yeah
so I get it